[BEEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to the first
episode on the Baseline--
Infrastructure Quest.
If you're a novice
cloud developer looking
for some hands-on practice
with GCP's core infrastructure
services, do yourself a favor
and enroll in this quest.
As a student, you'll
get practical experience
by taking labs that dive
into cloud storage, computing
engines, like Kubernetes,
and key application services,
like Stackdriver and
Deployment Manager.
By taking this quest, you'll
develop invaluable skills that
will apply to any GCP project.
After you're done with all
the labs in this quest,
you'll get this badge to
recognize your achievement.
You can add the badge to
your social media accounts
and your resume to let others
know about your new skills.
The way this
playlist works is you
watch a short video,
like this one,
where I'll be introducing
you to a lab on Qwiklabs
and give you a quick overview
of what you'll learn.
I'll also point you to
additional resources
where you can find more
information on each topic.
Once you're done
watching the episode,
you can head on over to
Qwiklabs and do the lab.
You can watch all the videos
and then do all the labs,
or you can work on the labs
and pop over to the videos
to find the
additional resources.
This is your quest, and you can
follow it however you'd like.
You don't even need to
do the labs in order.
I'm excited to get started.
So let's move on to our next
episode and our first lab
in the quest, Cloud
Storage, Quickstart Console.